I am NOT a bad guy I am a good guy who
runs over women with his car I'm not a
bad guy I'm a good guy who runs over
women with his car I am NOT a bad guy I
am a good guy who runs over women with
his car
why am I having such a hard time getting
my message across what are you doing
here hi how are you I'm not in character
yet apparently this computer has been
programmed to feel human emotions well
that's not how I'm program yeah
I'm sorry we only take MasterCard or
diners club that's it come on come on
here we go what are you doing here
you want to go today that's yeah getting
blood so Wow good for you good for you
how often can you actually donate blood
is there a limit I thought there was
well your body only has a certain amount
[Laughter]
do you hear me what what I can't hear
you why are you calling me my minutes
won't roll over I've used him today okay
there's a press release that
macushla he's watching Million Dollar
Baby he's gonna try to kill me I know I
used to be a temp here and now I'm your
boss and I understand how that must be
weird for you but well I'd do the scene
but BJ's not here 20 minutes to go time
20 seconds these are for you and one
flower
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay so we're all leaving for the
hospital it looks so fun it's for you
tree
I can take the brick we're leaving for
the hospital at 1:00 freedom
sorry let us go through that part okay
we're leaving for the hospital at 1:00
like a freedom treat I could do maybe
you could just change to you into an a
then it would say lanch party Kevin
would it really be better if it said
lanch party boy hey whose party it's
supposed to say launch easy Billy Barty
nobody cares about I am
to lose five pounds so I brought in a
fruit platter instead of cake for my
birthday but when Michael saw it he said
that's not cake and he threw it into the
trash so I was so mad and upset that I
dug it out of the trash and I hid the
entire thing in the women's bathroom do
you know how hard it is to eat all
righty I'm sorry I'm not professional
enough to do this I can't like oh hey
Toby could you close the door on your
way out
[Laughter]
I'm Toby
oh man wow I guess what surround-sound
means is that right over here channel
[Laughter]
two speakers we have two speakers honey
okay Michael I might have someone for
you here she's really sweet nice you
guys might actually get along all right
are you are you
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
what is wrong I've actually done like
six fun runs for summer this charity I
asked for assorted cutlery and I got
back spoons these are worthless I want
to understand what you're saying but
it's difficult for me when you use that
why do you have to say tone like that
she doesn't town I want to understand
what you're saying but it's difficult
for me to when you use that tone I want
to understand what you're saying but
it's difficult for me when you use that
Phyllis if you don't deal with things
right away they only get worse it's
called appeasement oh god that is so
disgusting
irony got it along you have 75 cents so
that means you could get anything in the
top row
so that means you could get anything in
the top row what's this a detonator
what spin I am gonna bang Holly she is
cute and helpful and she really seemed
to be okay I am so gonna bang Holly she
is Kim I am so gonna bang Holly she is
cute and helpful don't come near me
don't do your sexy moon dance you know
how I love it
Michael 5k means five kilometers you put
five thousand miles on this flyer come
in Hey
oh my god oh yeah no Michael
you said come in O so you're wondering
do we now have to sign one of those
office relationship well Prince Malik
later
you